hey everybody show McGuinness here with
a bit of depressing news Harmonix better
known is the studio behind rock band and
dance central has announced today that
its laid off 37 full-time positions as
part of a restructuring initiative a
representative told GameSpot quote
harmonics is in the process of
restructuring our organization to bring
it into alignment with our current and
future product development plans
unfortunately this means making the
difficult decision to reduce the number
of full-time staff we sincerely
appreciate the work of each and every
one of these employees harmonics is
working to ensure that those affected
are all well taken care of as we make
this change as part of the move harmonic
CEO Alex regalis has stepped aside from
his role as chief executive and will now
take over as chief creative officer
he'll be replaced by the company's
former vice president of operations and
publishing we at gamespot wish the best
of luck to those affected by the layoffs
today for more news on harmonics make
sure to go to gamespot com